.
>> Carley: A POLL HAS KIRKMEIR
UP BY TWO POINTS.
NBC REPORT ERBURNS IS DEFENDING
REPORTING ON JOHN FETTERMAN'S
HEALTH THIS WEEK AFTER THE MEDIA
BASHED HER FOR IT.
>> THAT IS FAIR THAT WAS THEIR
EXPERIENCE, WE CAN ONLY REPORT
OUR OWN.
OUR TEAM WAS FIRST TO BE IN THE
ROOM WITH JOHN FETTERMAN FOR AN
INTERVIEW, RATHER THAN VIA
REMOTE VIDEO CONFERENCE AND
MYSELF, BE AND MY CREW, FOUND
SMALL TALK BEFORE THE KAPGSZING
WAS DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
AUDITORY PROCESSING ISSUES I
MENTIONED.
>> Todd: JOE CONCHA IS LIVE IN
PERSON IN THE STUDIO, JOE, GREAT
TO HAVE YOU HERE, LET'S GO
THROUGH THE ATTACKS.
WE HAVE THEM ON THE BOARD.
"NEW YORK TIMES" OSHG P ED, JOHN
FETTERMAN IS DISABLED AMERICAN
WHO NEEDS TECHNOLOGY TO DO THEIR
JOB.
SO WHAT, "WASHINGTON POST," USE
OF CAPTIONS IS COMMON WITH
STROKE VICTIMS.
AND COVERED CRITICISM OF JOHN
FETTERMAN'S HEALTH.
FOCUS ON THE FIRST ONE FROM THE
TIMES.
SO WHAT, HE IS INTERVIEWING TO
BE A SENATOR AND YES, SOME JOBS
YOU CAN DO WHILE FOLLOWING A
STROKE, NFL QB AND ASCERTAIN,
WHERE YOU CAN'T.
IS THE MEDIA THAT DESPERATE TO
PUT THIS IN THE WIN COLUMN FOR
THE DEMOCRATS?
>> Joe: CAN I ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION WITH A QUESTION, TODD?
WHAT DO PEOPLE DO ON THE SENATE
FLOOR?
DEBATE WITHOUT A TELEPROMPTER
AND WHAT THIS IS DOING IS TAKING
AWAY FROM LOOKING AT FETTERMAN'S
POSITIONS, EVERYBODY FOCUSED ON
HEALTH ASPECT.
HE WANTS TO LET ONE-THIRD OF THE
PRISON POPULATION BACK OUT ON
THE STREET AND CRIME IS AN ISSUE
ON THIS RACE.
ACTIVISM, HERE IT IS, YOU HAVE
DID SHEA BURNS DOING HER JOB,
REPORTING SAYING WE SAT IN THE
ROOM WITH FETTERMAN, FIRST
REPORTING CREW TO DO SO AND THIS
IS WHAT I OBSERVED AS A
REPORTER.
SHE SHOULD BE COMMENDED FOR NOT
BOWING TO THE MOB, WHICH MAINLY
EXISTS ON TWITTER AND WE SAW
HEADLINES DOES SEEM TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION IN A LONG WAY, THE
PRESS IS DOING THIS TO TRY TO
PROTECT JOHN FETTERMAN, WHO IS A
MASSIVE STROKE AND CLEARLY HAS
NOT RECOVERED IN A WAY THAT CAN
MAKE PEOPLE COMFORTABLE HE CAN
DO HIS JOB EFFECTIVE LIE.
>> Carley: HERE IS MORE
CRITICISM, WATCH THIS.
>> LOTS OF JOURNALISTS UNLEASHED
ON HER.
>> IT WAS INAPPROPRIATE WHEN SHE
SAID DURING OUR SMALL TALK,
MAYBE IT IS HER.
>> Carley: SHE WAS DOING HER
JOB, YOU'RE A REPORTER, THIS IS
A SENSITIVE SUBJECT.
HE IS A STROKE VICTIM AND YOU
WANT HIM TO GET BETTER.
HE IS RUNNING FOR A JOB WHERE
YOU HAVE TO COMMUNICATE.
NOT LIKE SHE WAS CRITICAL OF HIM
IN ANY SIGNIFICANT WAY OTHER
THAN REPORTING WHAT SHE SPRNGSED
HERSELF.
>> Joe: PRECISELY, ALL THE
PEOPLE SPEAKING IN THE MONTAGE
YOU JUST PLAYED AND BEHIND THE
HEADLINES TODD READ, SHOULD BE
ASKING, WHY WON'T JOHN FETTERMAN
RELEASE HIS MEDICAL RECORDS?
IT IS FAIR THING TO ASK.
SENATE IS A SIX-YEAR CONTRACT.
MY MOTHER SUFFERED A STROKE AND
SHE DIDN'T COMPLETELY RECOVER
AND SINCE THIS HAPPENED IN MAY,
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE MAKING
BETTER PROGRESS IN THAT REGARD.
IF WE WANT TO SEE HOW WELL JOHN
FETTERMAN IS IN HIS ABILITY TO
SPEAK AND GIVE ANSWERS TO HARD
QUESTIONS, GIVE A PRESS
CONFERENCE.
HE IS YET TO DO THAT HERE, THE
FACT HE REFUSES TO DEBATE HIS
OPPONENT IN DR. OZ, ONLY A
COUPLE DAYS BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
>> Carley: TWO WEEKS BEFORE, YOU
HAVE TO WONDER THE EFFECT OF THE
ELECTION AND HOW IT WILL BE
COVERED.
>> Joe: JOHN FETTERMAN WON
ALREADY.
>> Todd: NO ONE IS MAKING FUN OF
THE DISABLED, THIS IS NOT
VIOLENCE AGAINST DISABLED, THIS
IS DETERMINATION IF THE MAN HAS
THE HEALTH CAPABILITIESS TO DO
THE JOB.
JOE CONCHA, YOU DO HAVE THE
HEALTH CAPABILITIES TO DO THIS
JOB.
>> Joe: YOU ARE SMART APPL